[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est pas une journée unique
quand même ça s'inscrit effectivement
dans un programme qui avait lieu tout
l'été qui s'appelle sous le soleil
exactement et qui a été organisée en
collaboration par la mairie d'orsay là
mais mjc d'orsay l'ensemble des
associations la participation de la cps
et l'établissement public du plateau de
saclay aussi l'idée était de proposer
des activités à la fois festives
ludiques et culturelles à l'ensemble des
forces et un avec sans doute un focus un
peu plus fort sur un public familial
pour pouvoir intéresser à la fois les
enfants mais et leurs parents donc des
ateliers qui permettent aux enfants de
découvrir de nouvelles activités et
souvent en fin de journée des spectacles
qui permettent à ce moment là aux
parents aussi qui trouvaient leur compte
aux intéressés j'ose dire et c'est un
peu ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
cette après midi on a eu beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont venus à l'atelier
jonglerie et ce soir à 18 heures on aura
les parents qui pourront participer
bénéficier aussi de ce spectacle et on a
toujours eu un public assez large avec
toutes les tranches d'âge qui viennent à
nos spectacles
on pensait important de pouvoir proposer
un programme d'activités à la fois
ludiques et culturelles aux or c'est un
sur un lieu en plus historique qui n'a
pas été investi durant les dernières
années et qui méritait que les anciens
puissent reprendre le goût et l'habitude
d'y venir parce que c'est quand même un
endroit assez exceptionnel et demain en
plus qui sera en plein coeur de ville de
coeur de ville
l'intérêt de corps de ville c'est d'une
part de délocaliser un peu si j'ose dire
les animations qui traditionnellement
ont lieu dans les trois quartiers
d'orsay qui sont le centre ville monde
et touré le guichet mais sur le plateau
évidemment il ya un programme très
important de développement sur ce
quartier de cordes ville qui est sur la
commune d'orsay et le fait d'investir
les lieux cet été redonne l'habitude aux
or c'est un qui parfois avait travaillé
sur le site de thalès qui étaient
implantés ici jusqu'à il ya quelques
années de revenir d'emprunter les
chemins qui montent depuis le guichet
jusqu'au plateau de faire un lien entre
le plateau de saclay qui est en train de
se développer de façon considérable et
le centre ville et de réinvestir les
lieux en profitant de toutes les
installations qui ont été
proposées et mises en place par le ps de
visiter la châtaigneraie et de profiter
de ce nouvel espace de vie qui est fort
intéressant et qui du coup donne vie à
ce nouveau quartier de cordes ville et
fait le lien avec le reste de la commune
[Musique]